Speaker 1: All right. Politics doesn't have to be
entertaining. It doesn't have to be entertaining
in the way that a TV show or a movie has to be
entertaining. In fact, it's a problem that in
many ways, our politics in the United States
has become one of the sideshow, like an action
movie or whatever the case may be, rather than
serious policy discussions. At the same time,
there's a difference between entertainment and
being a completely uninspiring and a pedantic
bore in the context of explaining to people what
you're going to do for them. That would say, Hey,
I think I'm going to vote for you. So when
I'm going to play some clips now for you of
Ron DeSantis, his speech yesterday in Iowa and
tell you that he seemed to be trying to bore the
crowd to death, it's not that I mean, DeSantis
needs to be doing the insults that Trump has
become known for or the nicknaming or any of
that. That's not what I'm saying. What I am
saying is that he is boring the crowd to death
with meaningless slogans and bullet points that
even he doesn't understand and certainly don't
connect to any important policy that would help
people. Here is DeSantis, for example, talking
about the debt deal that is being worked on,
and it seems that that has been reached.
Speaker 2: Do they now have a debt deal,
which they're acting like is going to change
things? We were careening towards bankruptcy
before this debt deal and the country is
still careening towards bankruptcy after
this debt deal. We need big reform to be able to
get our nation back on fiscal solid fiscal ground.
Speaker 1: What reform how does that relate
specifically to the economic situations of
the people in the crowd? The problem
with this sort of speech is that not
only is it retreading the same tired lines
that Republicans have tried for a while,
it's been years since this sort of Republicanism
was even at the center of the Republican Party.
And this is not in any way connecting with the
average voter about what the Santos is going
to do. Then DeSantis just shifts to woke, and
he talks about competing in the woke Olympics.
He just can't get away from talking about woke.
Speaker 2: Woke, Woke should not have to compete
in the woke Olympics just to qualify
for employment or to get into a college,
Merritt must trump identity politics.
Speaker 1: This is essentially his campaign.
And it couldn't be I mean, he it couldn't be less
inspiring. Thank you for being here today. Today,
we'll talk about how the history of the paperclip
has completely gone, woke at this point in time.
You know, paperclips are these small metal
devices. They used to hold sheets of paper
together, but now they represent woke ideology and
some people even bend them into LGBT shapes. I saw
Paperclip painted in the Pride flag colors, and
we're not going to do that in Florida. And if I'm
president, we're not doing that anywhere. Okay.
They're going to paper. You realize teachers who
want to talk about gender affirming care are
using colored paper clips. We're not going to
allow it in Florida and we're going to make the
entire country floor. It's meaningless stuff. It
just it doesn't do anything. It doesn't connect
with anyone. Here's one more clip of DeSantis
talking about a 14 dystopia under COVID.
Speaker 2: In Florida, we made the choice
to choose facts over fear. We chose education over
indoctrination, Right? And we chose to stand for
law and order over rioting and disorder. Sure,
we held the line when freedom itself hung in
the balance. I was not going to let the state of
Florida descend into some type of Asian dystopia
where people's freedoms were curtailed
and their livelihoods were destroyed. No,
we stood up for people's rights. We protected
people's jobs and small businesses and guaranteed,
like your governor did, that kids had a
right to be in school and get an education
in-person five days a week. In short,
Florida, we chose freedom over fascism
and we are better off for having done that.
Speaker 1: It seems like these speeches were
written by some kind of poor like by GPT one. You
know, it's not even like the stuff that three or
four can write for them, and it just does not have
winner written anywhere all over it. By the way,
for all of his bragging about COVID. Florida with
the 10th highest per capita COVID death rate,
10th highest per capita COVID death rate.
So not exactly something to brag about.